2017 is coming to a close and this is
now my fifth year reviewing a whole year
of anime but Before we jump into what
2017 did for anime what happened in the
rest of the world the eclipse happened
for America causing a nationwide purge
of sight for people who took the advice
of every possible outlet telling them
not to stare directly at it as a [ __ ]
dare
this was swiftly followed by
hallucinations of a giant man in black
armor with a massive sword shouting
angrily at the sky it was a tough year
for tragic events stories of sexual
harassment coming to light and North
Koreans threat ever stronger which is no
surprise that the biggest group of
people causing us to lose faith and
humanity this year was Rick and Morty
fans by completely losing their [ __ ]
caused by massive outrage over a bit of
teriyaki sauce mixed with ketchup and of
course the fidgets winter craze took
over the world showing the terrifying
power of having a mildly satisfying
feeling in your hands
in response the World Health
Organization advised people to start
take up smoking instead with new
research coming to life suggesting you
would pose a significantly less risk to
cancer but of course we're here to talk
about the last year in anime and
everything that happened in our
community of course I won't be able to
cover everything but I will do my best
so as we roll back the clock to winter
the community found some love during the
cold months to warm our icy hearts in
DreamWorks as highly acclaimed How to
Train Your Dragon waifu
[Music]
this year started off with some
wholesome goodness as Miss Kobayashi's
made dragon prove to us that the king of
cutes still firmly remains in Kyoto
animations hands it was the show that
grabbed the community for some reason I
mean I don't know what's so great about
Dragon and the maid outfit I mean sure
she's queuing or but I don't when you
see why the community would go crazy
about this lonely adult working woman
actually one day finds a dragon at her
doorstep who enthusiastically offers to
be her maid and thus we follow the daily
life of kobayashi as along the way she
meets an assortment of dragons who end
up growing a close bond to her wanting
to stay by her side of course making her
true name miss Kobayashi Stormborn of
House Targaryen mother of dragons
marika of cherry on this it was just a
heartwarming tale about family values
and how we can find family with the
people we meet and spend time with even
if those bonds aren't made by blood but
let's be real here we all know the true
reason we watch the show as Karnas Kunis
dominated the community for that season
clips and gifts flooded all of social
media with carnosine signifying the next
level of cute animal videos detailing
these terrifying ancient mythical
creatures becoming domesticated for our
viewing pleasure
oh boo boo boo boo boo who can destroy
the world to bring about the apocalypse
yes you can yes you can boo boo boo boo
boo boo on a side note the official
music video for the opie is one of the
most unintentionally entertaining things
to come out of this just because this
guitarist is the epitome of that
unimpressed nor me friend you see at
anime conventions being forced into
doing this weird weep [ __ ] that he
doesn't get and the rest of the winter
Fuko gave an anime adaptation for a
manga that caused the major controversy
for his pre-existing fans by completely
changing major plot points only to
diverge entirely by the second half of
the show while many argued the anime was
doomed from the beginning without enough
episodes to probably conclude the events
laid out in the beginning of the manga
it was clear that either way the
adaptation really got hit by a truck
away no it [ __ ] didn't after much
anticipation from its highly successful
ova x' studio trigger finally debuted
the first full season of boku no chibi
Potter academia despite the mostly
positive reception he received from
viewers and the hyper had going for it
it failed to make a big impact on the
community marking the first time fans
really felt the effect of a highly
anticipated anime being held hostage
behind the red bars of Netflix's prison
a pattern that would soon be felt more
as the
went by yo-yo Sankey gave us another
contender for Lally of the season with
the story of a middle-aged man trapped
in the body of a nine-year-old girl
during an alternate reality World War
one yes karna has her work cut out as
she may have her adorable eating scenes
but how can she possibly compete with
the precious smile of crazy rocket Lally
Hitler murdering hundreds of soldiers
cute rocky go shinji got another season
give me a chance to redeem myself from
the endless comments like God for
missing this masterpiece in last year's
run down so now that I've been given
this chance I can safely say that Marci
muna Kunz revenge was a symbol a harem
junk-food I actually enjoyed a lot a
tailor but an overly confident
narcissistic [ __ ] trying to get
revenge over a stoic cinder a [ __ ] who
rejects them ages ago because he was fat
which sounds cheesy and dumb and was
cheesy and dumb but somehow ended up
being the perfect popcorn M saimin
rom-com okay fine I'll talk about rocky
go past the first season somewhat
disconnected 45 minutes slow burner of a
first episode that turns me and a lot of
people off initially you've Rock ago
demonstrates some of the best that anime
has to offer it's a beautiful character
driven story told through rock ago
they're not so well known art form that
it is but the character surrounding this
concept are so well fleshed out and
compelling that it was simply a joy to
experience life from their shoes and
this season followed suit from the first
to definitely become one of the
contenders of anime of the year
handshake is gave us a highly ambitious
car crash about a group of kids who get
superpowers by holding hands and if that
sounds bad you don't worry that was the
best part of the show yes if the
audience one puts up by enough excessive
camera movements to induce motion
sickness then his visual style was so
ugly I now have a permanent phobia of
badly animated CG chains our favorite
lovable car some idiots returned for
another season in Kanna Sieber to giving
us the fun stupid fantasy adventures
that is basically the animated
experience of playing Dungeons & Dragons
with a group of junk pissheads scums
which gave us a genre about a group of
scummy people being scummy with each
other because everyone's in a
relationship where they'd rather be with
someone else that's right as an anime
setting cut filled where it's always MTR
o'clock so of course with such a recipe
it was only ever going to end one way
yep it's the return of everyone's
favorite old friend
if you
he happy happy clap your hands and
finally the surprise hit of the season
came with kimono friends which took
Japan by storm with this depiction of
cute little anthropomorphize anime girls
to which my first thought was wow I
[ __ ] wonder why but the series turned
out to be a light-hearted original
experience for anime that no one
expected cured by the fact that during a
promotional run of a zoo one of the
cardboard cutouts caught the affection
of a lone penguin great couldn't yes the
story of breakin and his wife who
exploded on the internet and how could
it not
it's [ __ ] adorable as of course yes
that has never had any obsession with
any animal ever before unfortunately a
few months later grape kindig pass away
and of course the enemy community
mourned at the loss of one of our own
showing that our love for wifey's
transcends gender belief and species
rest in peace great [ __ ] Jesus may have
died for our sins but great [ __ ] died
for our wife who's a spring rolled
around those much anticipation in the
air as two of the hottest properties in
the last few years were back and vying
for the top spot in the Battle of season
twos one was the old king finally back
after many years of anticipation and the
other was the new kid in the block
continuing to make a name for themselves
in this new era that's right
the boys were back in town
[Music]
after four years of waiting attack on
Titan return to us and it was almost
like it never left
Titans once again walked the line of
pants certainly terrifying to pan
fittingly stupids Aaron was still a loud
uptight [ __ ] who can stop failing in
life and once again we were given an
opening that everyone thinks they can
sing even though they only literally
know one word tonally however this
season was far different from the
previous one focusing more on mystery
and horror than all our action and hype
but despite being the sequel to one of
the hottest anime properties of all the
time the hype surrounding it was nowhere
near what it was during its peak in
season one showing us that waiting for
years probably wasn't the best thing to
do as this new seasonal anime climate
has given the community a collective
memory that lasts about three and a half
days while undoubtedly it was still
popular the series that rose up to take
the spotlight for the community was my
hero academia though the first season
was highly loved by Shonen fans it was
this season that really catapulted it
into sky-high popularity most likely for
longer run the absolute hype surrounding
his take on its structured series of
individual flights arc and for hosting
one of the standout fights in the year
for anime that's right boku no hero
academia versus my hero academia
I have nothing more to add over the
things I've said and have been saying
since last year's recap as it just
continues to be a very high-quality
shown in action show staying true to us
John Roos roots ultimately which title
won the battle season Jews well there's
only one way we can settle this what you
really want me to bring it back one last
time find
[Music]
in the rest of the season Kings avatar
gave China's first attempt at given the
world in eSports anime pals lesson
eSports anime and more and ex-pro making
a bunch of new friends by Dickey abouts
in bronze in anime smurfing the dyrus
chronicles Akashic records of I thought
we'd grown out of the battle Hara magic
highschool face by now anime gave us a
Magic High School where the most magical
thing was how they confused the stripper
outfit for a school uniform as only the
girls seemingly need to wear it it's
degrading objectifying and I am so
horrified that I want to meet the genius
who approved this seriously who thought
of this I need to shake his hand
tiny miniskirts
we got a continuation to our favorite
loud yellow haired ninja that everyone
expected to suck but actually turned out
to be a great homage to what made the
original anime appeal to us in the first
place while tackling it in a new enough
way to keep it fresh in Naruto son child
of burritos dad the suffering continued
as bizarre 2017 continued kicking fans
while they were down who has still left
in agony from last year thinking well at
least us no way can look any worse than
bizarre 2016 oh god what have you done
thank you you guys complaining about I
mean it's do but the sleeper here the
season will see kikiki lay a grounded
portrayal of teenage relationships that
unfortunately got swept under the masses
of big shows this season one of the most
realistic takes of adolescent romance I
have seen recently that breaks all the
[ __ ] conventions you normally see in
anime like Merv a dramatic melodrama
parents are actually present and they
even show the superpower granted only to
us introverts communication through
awkward silences meta was taken to a
whole new level as recreate as gave us a
show about anime and game characters
being transported to the real world and
meeting their creators yes we had budget
saber meeting her author should have
been a monogatari villain versus should
have been a Joe Joe character and Madoka
Magica causing collateral damage with
her completely own Pia friendship powers
god I love this [ __ ] show the only
thing missing was for an essay kai
character to be transported to their
world where you would get confused think
he was transported back to his homeworld
Kaito the right answer gave us an
interesting thought experiment of how
easy it would be to advance the human
race given new technology that could
give us infinite resources and
understanding of our universe while
interesting it was obviously very
unrealistic as in reality it would never
be the stupidly difficult to unite the
human race under a technology that
everyone would be able to use equally
without being controlled by people for
their own game ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha sort orator iya is it wrong to
pick up girls in the dungeon on the side
gave us a side story to dine machi
featuring not Hestia but even this
season and had competition for most
overly convoluted title based on a light
novel as what do you do at the end of
the world
are you busy will you save us question
marks included attempted it's best to go
over the word-count limit for new anime
titles on now and finally era manga
sensei exploded onto the scene giving us
the harem incest bates lolly fanservice
absolutely none of us asks for but we
all watched
anyway of course following from REM oh
you would have to do something special
to make waves in the community and that
it certainly did combining elements of
the absolute lowest parts of anime into
one show and
taking it just that level beyond there
was tasteless it was pandering yeah it
was downright questionably illegal and
just when you think you couldn't get any
lower it asked you to hold his beer
while it jumps in the dumpster to take
us further below hi
[Music]
despite the fact he was an absolutely
awful show we just couldn't stop
watching before somehow enjoying the
experience then accepting it for the
awful garbage that it was and for better
or worse this year would not have been
the same without it thank you every
manga sensei for providing us with such
entertainment over the years and an
endless well of memes
thank you for uniting us and making us
realize that we are all just a bunch of
the generous at heart
goodbye respectable taste in anime hello
FBI registry the otaku fandom have
spoken again and the final answer to the
rest of the world is that anime is trash
and so are we
being party hey guys hope you enjoyed
the video if you would like to check out
all the previous anime year reviews
click on this playlist here just to
check out just how much anime has
changed in the last five years this is
my fifth year doing it and if part two
is out the link will be right over the
video I put here as a placeholder which
should hopefully be in a few days anyway
that's it for me I will see you guys
later